13 years after the first Harry Potter book was published,...
...I'm still astonished and delighted by the response the stories met.
Even though the seventh book and the eighth film have now been completed,...
...I'm still receiving hundreds of letters every week...
...and Harry's fans remain as enthusiastic and inventive as ever.
So, I'd like to take this opportunity to say thank you,...
...because no author could've asked for a more wonderful, diverse, and loyal readership.
I'm thrilled to say that I am now in a position to give you something unique.
An online reading experience unlike any other.
It's called Pottermore.
It's the same story with a few crucial additions.
The most important one is you.
Just as the experience of reading requires that the imaginations...
...of the author and reader work together to create the story,...
...so Pottermore will be built in part by you, the reader.
The digital generation will be able to enjoy a safe,...
...unique, online, reading experience built around the Harry Potter books.
Pottermore will be the place where fans of any age can share,...
...participate in, and rediscover the stories.
It will also be the exclusive place to purchase digital audio books.
And for the first time, e-Books of the Harry Potter series.
I'll be joining in too...
...because I will be sharing additional information I've...
...been hoarding for years about the world of Harry Potter.
Pottermore is open to everyone from October,...
...but a lucky few can enter early, and help shape the experience.
Simply, follow the owl.
Good luck!